une fois le choc de son renvoi du
conseil des ministres passent et sylvie
d'amour accepte de nous recevoir sur ses
terres à mirabel
je suis fatigué fatigué de tout seul de
tout ce tourbillon médiatique l'offre
mais vous que c'est un gros la politique
c'est dur c'est dur quand on travaille
avec de la perception un groupe parce
qu'on n'a pas la chance d'expliquer ce
qu'on fait c'est justement pour
combattre la perception qu'elle n'a rien
fait pour les premières nations au cours
des deux dernières années qu'elle veut
nous parler à la réponse que je donnais
d'autant fait pas parce que je suis pas
devant les caméras que je travaille peau
d'abord sur la mise en oeuvre des
recommandations de la commission vient
concernant les relations entre les
autochtones et les services publics
la mort consternante de joyce et chaque
one à l'hôpital de joliette a fait dire
au premier ministre que le dossier
n'avançait pas si vite à son goût
effectivement on aurait dû aller un peu
plus vite mais moi j'étais dans la même
la même visage était à la même vitesse
que les autochtones
j'aurais pu moi très bien aller beaucoup
plus vite que ça tout seul mais le but
c'était de le faire avec eux pour eux
c'est que si on n'arrivait pas à avancer
ensemble c'est moi qui était stoppée moi
j'avais j'avais les lys ou nécessaire
les 200 millions de dollars prévus pour
donner suite à la commission vient
d'hommes dans un coffre se désole sylvie
d'amour je suis convaincu qu'il serait
arrivé s'il y avait pas eu la pandémie
ci avait pas eu ce conflit-là entre chef
picard et moi qui je peux même pas
expliquer pourquoi je faudra peut-être
lui demander à lui aussi elle reconnaît
que son lien avec le chef de l'assemblée
des premières nations ghislain picard
s'est brisée mais elle insiste sur une
chose ses relations avec tous les autres
chefs étaient très bonnes si j'étais
l'élément qui avait une problématique
avec le chef picard tout subitement
passé j'ai vu quand on va rester chez
lui quand c'est quelqu'un qui ne me
parlait
les autochtones mois s'il faut qu'on
compense le ministre parce qu'on veut
avancer avec les nations je me passais
tous et les déçus de ne pas avoir pu
annoncer ses projets des petits
déjeuners dans toutes les écoles
autochtones des scellés c'est mieux
orientée sur leurs besoins
un projet de loi pour que des parents du
québec plus connaître la vérité au sujet
de la disparition de leur bébé dans les
années 80 sylvie dames on voulait aussi
créé le service aux autochtones du
québec qui aurait regroupé et fait la
promotion de tous les programmes pour
eux comme son premier ministre
elle n'était cependant pas prête à
reconnaître le racisme systémique
est ce que c'est un racisme colonialisme
est-ce que c'est faux faux faux nomi
sketch un casse-tête pour vous comme
ministre devant gérer ça c'était pas un
casse tête pour moi parce que moi je
voulais pas m'arrêter au monde je
voulais comme qu'on en dise
mais il n'avait pas toute la latitude
qu'il aurait souhaité pour agir
les premières nations veulent surtout
négocié avec le premier ministre
qu'elles considèrent comme leur
véritable vis-à-vis est-ce que les mêmes
difficultés attendent son successeur ian
lafrenière difficile pour elle de penser
le contraire ici véronique prince radio
canada à mirabel